[Audio Length: 0:16:10]
RECORDING COMMENCES:
Evan Carmichael:
He's an American businessman, investor,
self-help author, motivational speaker and
radio personality. He's the founder of the
Rich Dad Company. He has an estimated net
worth of $80 million. He's Robert Kiyosaki,
and here are his Top Ten Rules For Success.
Robert Kiyosaki:
The last thing I want to talk about, debt,
is one of the best investments I've made because
I started off with no money, like most people.
My first investment, was a little $18,000
condo in Hawaii, and I made a whopping $25
a month. I didn't make much money on that
deal, but every time I did an investment,
be it real estate or business, I got smarter
because experience makes you smarter.
I started with just a little $18,000 unit.
I broke out my credit card. I paid the $2,000
down payment with my credit card, so it was
100% financed. Now, most experts will tell
you, "That's stupid. You don't do that",
but if you know what you're doing, you can
do it.
A number of years ago, I bought a $7 million
commercial building. I paid for it with zero
down. Every month, after everything is paid
for, it puts about $30,000 a month income
in my pocket, or $360,000 a year for no money
down. There is a price of having a good education
or a bad education. A good education is knowing
the good debt versus bad debt and how debtors
can win, if you know what you're doing.
I don't know what the heck people think about
money, but that's what I get a lot of, is
this, Well, money is not spiritual.
I'm just saying it's your attitudes, a person's
attitude towards money. I make a lot of money,
but I give a lot. You know what I mean?
Male Speaker:
Through philanthropy.
Robert Kiyosaki:
It goes to biblical principle. The more you
give, the more you receive. When I meet somebody
who doesn't have any money, it just means
that they're not giving something.
Male Speaker:
Yes.
Robert Kiyosaki:
A lot of times, there are people who would
like more, but they're not giving anything.
Male Speaker:
Yes.
Robert Kiyosaki:
They're like my poor dad. He belonged to the
labor unions, and he wanted to work less and
get paid more. That's anti-religious to me.
If you want to get paid more, work more, give
more. That's how I see it.
The discipline I had to get into was I was
paying myself first, even when I had no money,
and when I have all these bill collectors
calling me, I use them as inspiration. [laughter]
You know what I mean?
Oprah:
Really?
Robert Kiyosaki:
When the government's hounding you, the bill
collectors are calling... because I've been
broke, so I can understand what it feels like
to be broke. When those guys are calling you,
instead of shrinking, going into the shell
and eating my pizza
Oprah:
Yes.
Robert Kiyosaki:
I use it as motivation to go out and make
more money. I used my bill collectors as motivation,
and that's why I paid myself first, even though,
sometimes, I wasn't paying
Oprah:
What would you pay yourself?
Robert Kiyosaki:
I always bought assets. I'd buy a house, or
I'd put money in the bank, this like this,
but it was just a habit. It's exactly what
you're talking about. It's up here.
Oprah:
It's about changing the way you think. That's
what the whole book is about.
Robert Kiyosaki:
That's it because we are our biggest asset.
We are also our biggest liability.
The common wisdom, the old intelligence idea
is to diversify. What I believe in is something
else; it's increase your financial IQ, your
financial intelligence and, instead, FOCUS.
What FOCUS stands for is this; FOCUS is Follow
One Course Until you're Successful. That's
what I did in 1973. I signed up for my first
real investment course, and I just did it
and did it and did it. I bought this one little
$18,000 place, and I did it, again. I did
it, again, and I did it, again, until the
point where I understood it. Then I went into
becoming an entrepreneur. I did it, and I
did it and did it. I'm still learning, and
I'm still learning about real estate.
In 1966, I got into oil, when I went to work
for the Standard Oil Company. Today, I'm still
focusing. I invest in oil and oil and oil,
and I don't diversify. It doesn't mean I don't
lose. Sometimes I lose. Sometimes I make mistakes
and all this, but I just don't buy good is
with all the bad. If you're going to be successful
as an investor, diversification is good for
the average investor. If that's what you want
to be, have a good life. What I'd rather do
is be able to know the good ones from the
bad ones, the good investments from the bad
investments, the good advisors from the bad
advisors, what's good for me and what's not
good for you because what I do is not necessarily
what's going to work for you, and vice versa
here. That's why I really think, instead of
diversification or diversify, the new rules
of money say follow one course until you're
successful, and then keep doing it because
once you find the way of being successful,
you can do it again and again and again.
The thing is, you see, economies go up; economies
go down. We might go into a depression, worldwide.
Like I said, France is in very big trouble.
Germany is okay. England is in big trouble.
China is in trouble. If we go with that, we
go into worldwide depression, and it might
take 10 years to come out of it. During these
times is the best time. I have made more money
in the last three years than ever before in
my life. I bought five golf courses last year
on a bank
Male Speaker:
That's impressive.
Robert Kiyosaki:
Yes. Well, the bank
Male Speaker:
Five golf courses.
Robert Kiyosaki:
Yes, and Donald bought 10. They're giving
them away.
Male Speaker:
[laughter] No one told me.
Robert Kiyosaki:
Yes, but you have to know how to operate them.
Male Speaker:
Yes.
Robert Kiyosaki:
You have to be an entrepreneur.
Male Speaker:
Yes.
Robert Kiyosaki:
The banks just call you up, and they say...
There was this one. It was five. It was five
golf courses and one hotel.
Male Speaker:
In the states?
Robert Kiyosaki:
In Arizona, yes, golf mecca.
Male Speaker:
Yes.
Robert Kiyosaki:
This Japanese company had it, and they asked
me if I wanted to buy it, about five years
ago, for 260 million. I said, "It doesn't
make sense. It doesn't make sense at 260 million."
They told me I didn't know what I was doing,
this and that. "Okay, bye." Then, one
year ago, the summer, Citibank called up and
says, "You want those golf courses?" They
gave me the money to buy them.
Just to reiterate, in approximately 1975,
I came out with this product. We're extremely
successful, but we kept running out of money.
The more successful we got, the more we ran
out of money. That's when I went to my rich
dad, and I tried to borrow $100,000. He chewed
me out. He says, "Why would I invest in
a dumb product when you have a bad business?"
That's when he began to teach me the next
level of my entrepreneurial education.
It's not about the product. It's about how
to design a business that doesn't need me
to keep raising the capital. In other words,
how do you design a business that keeps raising
money automatically? Today, The Rich Dad Company
is cash rich. Cash keeps pouring in because
the ability to raise money constantly was
designed into the business.
Once again, this is the diagram. This is the
B-I Triangle. These are the eight pieces that
make up a business. When a business is hurting,
oftentimes, it's because one of these eight
pieces is missing. For example, many times,
people say, "I have a great product,"
but their legal is really bad. Or their communication
systems are bad, or their internal order processing
is bad. Or the manufacturing is bad, or the
marketing is bad. Or they have bad cash flow
management.
Another part of your financial IQ is to know
there are three types of income. If you're
going to, say, work hard, most people are
working hard for earned income, and that's
what these guys are working for. The trouble
with earned income in America, your tax rate
is approximately 50%. Or, as Warren Buffet
says, it's a shame that his secretary pays
a higher percentage in taxes than he did,
although he makes billions of dollars. When
you say to a child, "Go to school and get
a safe, secure job," you're telling them
to work for earned income, the worst type
of income.
The second type of income is portfolio income,
and today, as I speak, I'm going to try and
change this. It's about 20%, and portfolio
income is generally known as capital gain.
If I buy a stock for $10 and I sell it for
$50, the $40 is taxed 20%. Or if I buy a house
for 100,000 and I sell it for 200,000, that's
a capital gains-type event, so you'd pay a
lower tax for that.
The third type of income, which is the best
type of income, excuse me, I can't spell,
again, is passive income. This is income
that just comes in on a regular basis. One
of the reasons I am wealthy and was able to
retire at a young age is because I worked
hard for passive income, not earned income.
I don't flip real estate, generally. Not portfolio
income; I don't flip stocks. I want passive
income.
Today, the new rules of money, it's important
to understand what are you going to school
to become; E, S, entrepreneur or investor.
What kind of income are you working hard for;
earned, portfolio or passive? If you know
what you're doing, you can pay 0% taxes legally,
and this be done all over the world. People
are saying, "You can't do it in my country."
Well, these people can't do it in any country,
but in most parts of the world, governments
need these people. They're always giving tax
incentives for investors and business owners
who are for passive income. Those are some
of the new rules of money. It's really know
what you're working hard at and what kind
of work are you performing, what kind of income
are you working hard for.
Well, most successful entrepreneurs have gone
bust. Henry Ford, an old-time entrepreneur,
he went bust five times. Look at Steve Jobs.
Male Speaker:
Yes.
Robert Kiyosaki:
His own board fired him.
Male Speaker:
Yes.
Robert Kiyosaki:
Bill Gates was taken before the Supreme Court
for monopolistic practices.
Male Speaker:
Right.
Robert Kiyosaki:
Even my friend, Donald Trump, went down a
billion dollars.
Male Speaker:
Yes.
Robert Kiyosaki:
I only went down a million. The average person
is so afraid of those losses they never get
ahead because at school, they teach you if
you make a mistake or if you fail, you're
a failure. That's not real life. A baby learns
to walk by standing up and falling down, standing
up and falling down. Our school system punishes
you for making mistakes. That's why my poor
dad, an academic, was so unsuccessful. He
was terrified of making mistakes.
The key to raising money... This is Ken McElroy's
company. It's called MC Companies. Ken McElroy's
business is in the business of acquiring assets.
That's why his company gets richer and richer
and richer. Every year he adds, probably,
1,000 new apartment units to his inventory,
so Ken's company gets richer and richer because
MC Company is designed to increase assets.
Poorly-designed businesses never have any
assets. They have huge liabilities. I trust
that makes sense to you.
Ken McElroy's business gets stronger and stronger
and stronger because, every year, he's increasing
in more assets. The Rich Dad Company gets
stronger and stronger and stronger because,
every year, we add more assets. This year,
we're adding franchising to our mix. Also,
Rich Brother Rich Sister, the book, has come
out. We come out with The Real Book of Real
Estate, et cetera, et cetera. Everyone, on
those products, every year, continues to send
money into our product. That's an idea of
a well-designed business, if you have a well-designed
business. I don't care if it's for real estate
or making cash flow board games; if it's well-designed,
investors will give money to you because "this
is a well-designed business."
I think the big mistake is I hear so many
people say it's important to save. That's
ridiculous, and the reason that's ridiculous
is because what happened in 1971 is crucial.
In 1971, the U.S. dollar stopped being money.
In 1971, the U.S. dollar became a currency.
What that meant is Richard Nixon, in 1971,
the president, took us off the gold standard.
That's like giving an alcoholic free reign
to the bar, or it's like giving somebody who
can't control their spending unlimited credit
cards. What's happening is all the savers,
today, are losers.
The problem with 1971 is that the federal
government keeps printing money, so the value
of your money keeps going down. These people,
"I'm saving, saving, saving." If you notice,
as the value of the dollar goes down, prices
go up. They call this inflation. You look
at it. In 1997, oil was about, I think, $10
a barrel. Ten years later, it's about $135
a barrel. Let's say it's inflation, but really,
what it is is the dollar's value coming down.
Savers are getting wiped out today. To keep
saying to yourself and to your kids to save
money, that is not the new rule. That's an
old rule.
A very big problem for most people is stop
using the word "save" and use the word
"hedge." You've got to hedge your money,
hedge against losses. When I buy a stock,
I put a hedge in. I put a stop-loss or a put
inside of it, or a call. Whatever I'm doing,
I want to stop it. Today, I won't save money.
I'm hedging.
In 1997, I started investing in oil, gold
and silver, so as a dollar a drop, oil, gold
and silver went up. I'm not betting so much
on oil, gold and silver. I'm betting against
the U.S. dollar. That's why this idea that
you're going to tell people, "You need to
save money," that's really, really an obsolete
idea because the idea went obsolete in 1971.
The U.S. dollar, in the last few years, has
lost almost 80% of its purchasing power. The
prediction is, because this has happened throughout
history... It happened thousands of years
ago, with the Romans, with the Greeks, with
the Germans, with the English, the Japanese
and the Chinese. Every time they've made money
into a currency, something you could print,
unlimited, every time that has happened, the
currency has gone to its true value, which
is zero.
I am afraid, as this economic volatility continues,
the savers who are operating by the old rules
of money are just going to get wiped out because
the purchasing power of their dollar is going
to go down. Even with the bank paying you
5% to 10% interest, you can't keep up with
the banks printing money. That's the old rule
of money, is saving money. The new rule is
hedge. You've got to be able to see what's
coming up as something else is coming down.
Evan Carmichael:
Thank you so much for watching. I made this
video because thebthong [ph] asked me to.
If there is a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next, leave it in the comments
below, and I'll see what I can do. I'd also
love to know which of Robert Kiyosaki's top
10 rules had the biggest impact on you. Leave
it in the comments, and I'm going to join
in the discussion. Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe, and I'll see you soon.
END OF RECORDING